Android Q beta is now available which
brings us one step closer to the final
release we want to make sure your
applications works properly by the time
and require updates are released to the
public in this video we will discuss the
Android Q beta program its timeline
available developer resources and
explain the two options you have for
testing it installing it on your device
or using an emulator image to give you
another view on the release process the
first three beta my son's provide an
early test and develop an environment to
help you identify compatibility issues
in your current apps a bit of for you
will have access to the final API is an
SDK to develop with as well as updated
beta system images to test system
behaviors and features also starting
beautiful you will be able to publish
apps to device running Android Q at the
official API level a bit of 5 and 6 you
will have release candidate builds which
includes the final ap is a near final
system images as you test and develop We
strongly recommend keeping your
development environment up-to-date as
beta updates are released the Android Q
preview SDK includes changes that are
not compatible with some older versions
of Android studio for the best
development experience with the Android
Q preview SDK will recommend that you
install the latest version of Android
studio after you open Android studio
download and install the Android Q
previous decay using the SDK manager you
will also need to update your platform
build tools to version 28 or higher
finally you can create virtual device by
downloading the Q image and use it as
the deployment target for your
application if you have a pixel device
you can install Android Q beta on your
phone to download the beta go to gto /
Android beta and obtain to the beta
program after restarting your device you
can navigate to the system update screen
on your phone and tap the Update button
to download and install Q if you want to
revert your phone to Android PI after
you test you can simply opt out of the
beta program from
same address and updates your device
from the system update screen as before
be aware that this process will remove
or locally saved data on your device
with the birth preparations complete you
can build your app and then conduct
basic compatibility testing on behavior
and privacy changes finally update the
target SDK in your Gradle file for
further testing and adoption of new
features for more information on new
features and changes in queue check out
the links in the description of the
video enjoy android q leave us feedback
on your experience using the beta we've
provided several ways to capture his
comment including a bug tracker see you
soon
[Music]